you
nothing like a [__] pipe full of some
[__] killer on a beautiful Sunday
morning easy like Sunday morning like my
man line already said
there you go
breaking up a [__] good stuff eating
I'm saying on a Sunday morning you think
I'm gonna show up here with some [__]
Harvey homo weed [__] no we show up with
the [__] vest okay you wanna be the
best you got a smoke the best look at
the sun's out the birds are chirping God
gave you another day to wake up and tell
these [__] to sue call I mean
get you understand me uncle Joey here
waking you up early I just got back from
the church hate the [__] little
cracker and god I didn't touch the wine
it's flu season I put a couple dollars
in the basket and I got the [__] out of
there why because you got to go pay
respect from time to time for the man of
[__] steel next time he'll show up
with a shotgun instead of a Bible you
know I'm saying anyway uncle Joey here
to wish you a [__] shrimp and this
week we're 22 push-ups write down your
goals who gives a [__] with that thing
it's what you're thinking that matters
do you realize that [__] it's what
you're thinking that matters you're just
too scared to [__] say it
so get your life together it's a whole
new week to think about this week is you
get another chance to start over if he
ate 200 xanaxs last week and honestly
Todd's [__] today's your lucky day
hit a meeting and start from today but
Joey what's the story blow the holy
smoke on me all right all ready let's
get this [__] [__] mule on
the road you don't say
cuz if you don't get the mule on the
road how you gonna make some [__] gay
this Sunday March 3rd we're all even
we're all [__] at zero now you gotta
[__] make it happen throughout the
month you gotta get up every morning you
gotta go for the [__] throat who
gives a [__] with that thinking you
understand me you gotta be aggressive in
today's world it's a different [__]
world I don't if you're 25 strap a pair
on [__] then get no [__] easier your
college degree means you gots today it's
all about high balls and [__] soul
jack you gotta get in there you gotta
get your elbows dirty you gotta get your
hands dirty roll up your sleeves have
you ever thought about that
what do you think the [__] Bluebird
of happiness is gonna knock on your door
just give you a check because you're you
[__] you you better get up and no one is
to be [__] hungry to get to that goal
that you're trying to reach but let me
tell you something I got the reef is of
reef is today I stumped by the [__]
Russians you know they don't give a [__]
about nothing the Russians and the
Armenians that's why I love them yeah I
mean is it I'm gonna rules what [__]
rules what rules it's like my world we
make our own [__] rules we stick to
them you don't tell me what to sell
there's no selling debt there you go who
the [__] are you kidding me
oh it smells me [__] the Mackenzies
burns [__] after the fight last night
did you see that big fat [__] ass you
just sitting there going Jesus Christ I
got I wish I could go on a [__]
Korean missile headfirst right inside
[__] sweaty BJJ muffler bloody way
I'm getting a Harvey Weinstein minute
you know I'm saying it's the Lord's Day
[__] you got a hugger you're family you
got to make [__] somebody's day cuz
that's what it's most important you want
good commie you got [__] can go your way
make somebody's day you got that last
joint give it up to somebody who needs
it more than you see what happens the
[__] blue bird a reefer drop a
[__] bomb a [__] reef run you
understand me but anyway
let's keep smoking a little pile here we
got together what am I gonna wake you up
at 9:00 in the morning to show up with
[__] haha sneeze I told you guys a
million times I'm not running a [__]
charity out there you gotta take that
immigrant blood that runs through your
[__] jeans that was hungry today your
grandfather when he [__] came here
were your great-great grandfather with a
nickel on this balk and a pair of [__]
shoes what was he thinking
you think he was thinking my Starbucks
or [__] oh boy or whatever he was
thinking about how to get down how to
[__] throw down and how to [__]
keep what the [__] he had and that's
what the problem with his today nobody
wants to know everything's a [__]
joke everything's a [__] noob but
suck my dick jack walk [__] get
those roller skates but anyway you know
what time it is the church comes out
tomorrow morning nice and early for you
see you have something on [__] Monday
morning you know if I'm in town if I
can't travel I gotta fill your Monday
morning cuz I understand the importance
of that you want to get to we started it
right you want to get to we started with
your uncle Joey I don't way me if I had
an uncle Joey I'd be hanging out with
him too I'm getting older but I'm
getting better every [__] day people
I'm a lot better than when I was
yesterday that's all that [__]
matters tomorrow
I don't know dick about manana today I'm
gonna tell you today I'm gonna swing
think I'm gonna write jokes I was only
gonna old man jujitsu I woke up to wait
and I wanted to go to church anyway you
know the [__] deal man
so I might catch 12 o'clock tonight I
might do a little strength a couple
cattle bowels a nice little [__] 40
minute walk burn like ten points and I'm
ready for my way and at Weight Watchers
tomorrow you understand me I'm looking
tip-top Magoo chin up ahead to check out
the [__] hairdo
this is Nicky eyelashes 1956 up in the
Bronx before he joined the Sharks
oh you know what we podcast we do comedy
shows what would the [__] are you
kidding this is the best part of our
dank together family with them tell me
you you wouldn't me and they want to be
with us [__] them [__] up at dick and
Polly shorty go ahead with Vito Manali
or whatever his [__] name is we're
gonna tattoo and put a scope cap I'll
let people know you're cool we don't
need two people always cool we are
[__] cool what a baddest [__]
in the room you know I'm saying we walk
in a room or like oh no [__] I got the
biggest dick on this [__] and
that's just the way it rocks them you
want to get down we'll get that whatever
the [__] you want to do I'm always ready
you know me may the Lord's always in my
corner but I always got a piece close by
let that booty [__] it but I don't need
that aggravation of my wife I'm just
trying to be a good guy we're trying to
put a podcast together we're trying to
get some laughs and smoke some [__]
reefer and that's it that's all what
it's about everything else is [__]
you're a [__] about power takes I have
to [__] that 12:00 I took my wife out to
dinner last night
there were two [__] couples I had to
be about 35 the peace and the way that
came back and said you know only we
don't have that wine in 1971 you should
have seen these two parties they're
gonna hop my car well what are we gonna
do it out drinking beer you two [__]
[__] and the wives are like oh my
god this so smart because they know
about woman get the [__] out here if
there's another time the place I would
have stabbed them both but I owe you
people responsibility I can't lay you
down I can't let you down you follow me
I gotta stick to my word and you gotta
stick to yours we're gonna [__] take
over slowly by slowly well like that
finger yes it's coming you just don't
know when it's gonna land you're
following me
the ice house is sold on our Saturday
night working out with uncle Joey March
21st Nayak you got the Late Show left
the first one sold that's all you got
it's ten o'clock and then I'm in the
next day there's the first week to April
I'm in [__] Albuquerque New Mexico me
to do the Winkeljohn podcast I'm gonna
go down there throw a couple sidekicks
for Jesus have a half a heart attack cuz
that's in the [__] hills in no way if
I can't breathe down here what am I
chance is up there I'm saying but hey
I'm happy I'm happy you came out and
said all the Uncle Joe you know I love
you [__] with all my heart I
[__] around I cracked stupid jokes but
the most important thing is you
[__] don't give us a [__] go
for it
take a chance Columbus did go for it if
you don't somebody else will and you
know I'm saying if you don't somebody
else will ain't no [__] ain't no
[__] model magazine but I don't give
a [__] I went for it they could all suck
my [__] dick every day that I exist
people get more depressed cuz they were
like [__] this fat [__] felon [__]
this fat felon you forgot was DNA k from
from the island of Cuba mixed with some
[__] Hoboken
which means American ingenuity mixed
with the [__] Sicilians see you that
an immigrant with an immigrant but a
little American are you [__] kidding
me who's gonna [__] stop you yeah so
what Frankie got stopped what are you
gonna do he's been around for 15 [__]
years eventually you know somebody's
gonna take out what don't you guys see
the [__] progression
what happened telling guys you were
watching 10 years ago I'm surprised
Frank he's still around I still gotta
hang my hat out to him he's one of the
toughest dudes out there if you hate on
Frankie you're a [__] [__] you
follow me tougher than that but right
now it's not about Frankie it's about
two weeks your [__] Russian
against the [__] tomorrow that's April
7th what am I talking about my dates all
[__] up here but anyway don't matter
nothing that matters
you what you're gonna do this weekend
how you gonna [__] do it you're gonna
write your goals you're gonna look that
[__] the facing but I want this
[__] job I want to do this you know
I'm looking the man in them because
that's the toughest dude you know what I
was doing coke at night and I'd go to
piss I would never look at myself in the
mirror hmm not cuz I'm an ugly
[__]
I just didn't want to see myself in that
condition I don't know if I ever told
you people this now I can't wait to look
in the mirrors ugly as I am I look in
the mirror and I know whatever I'm
telling that mirror I get stick to it
and that's the most important thing can
you stick to the [__] mirror all
right now because everything else is
[__] [__] I smoked another ball I
don't want you to say Joey you wasted my
[__] time today we got this one I
don't even know to three balls who gives
a [__] oh yeah sounds like my ass off
with that Swiss Chris oh my god I've
been taking some shits it looks like the
[__] beach in Atlantic City Jesus
fall and [__] uh bubble gum and
toothpicks I should have toothpick that
they must have gonna be LPA that the
[__] four start dying in 78
anyway your church will be ready for you
tomorrow morning 8:00 a.m. 6:00 a.m.
whatever the [__] you want ready a rock
Big John McCarthy you know I love you
[__] don't forget the ice
houses sold out I'm sorry
you still got chances up there up in
[__] Nayak I want to see the Bronx
representing I want to see [__]
old-school Brooklyn representing I want
to see Queens representing some [__]
Met fans in this [__] I want
some met bad some Yankee bad so I wanted
more Jes Jeff I want the whole [__]
crew up there for ten o'clock show I'm
gonna take over [__] Nyack that night
you understand me anyway god bless you
and your families have a [__] great
day don't let nobody tell you dick
you're the Captain Kirk the [__]
Enterprise their buddies slinging dick
it's you who's got a problem tell them
on for Joey sent you because at the end
of the day or you didn't get my my tail
out Binga sorry they didn't get my
mother [__] boom I see you don't say
quite to know where we might this along
I walked I may didn't get my mom LM over
on Booker I'm a method
in the words of Ricky Ricardo I love you
[__] see you tomorrow same
bat-time same bat-channel